[Music]
in case you confused it with new york
state
as if that's a thing
[Music]
no one but loki sees this and sure maybe
they send this in the cinemasins video
but if you expect me to cross-reference
marvel tv sins with marvel cinemasins
you have grossly overestimated the
amount of work i'm willing to do today
loki low-key logos go slow flow so low
though solo left me loco so i loathe the
show
this condensation is never seen or heard
from again in this episode
pay off your setups marvel
this location title did help me realize
the brightness setting on my tv was way
too high but even after correction i
refuse to believe that this font color
on
this background passed any sort of
contrast ratio test
this muzzle is just easily removable is
that part of the design it's not like
it's really attached anywhere so why
didn't it fall off
you know like the handcuffs apparently
did i am loki
roll commercial and i am burdened with
glorious purpose
fine go ahead get the episode title in
there too now you get a double roll
commercials and an extra sin for
interrupting me
you're now moving at 1 16 speed
but feeling all that pain in real time
mondays
also this is great on a couple levels
loki getting served in the comical way
it goes on for too long and you realize
it's not just slow motion but loki's
time has
actually slowed down but still and more
importantly can there be a difference in
the speed at which someone feels pain
especially blunt force trauma to the
head that's what really needs to be
explained
i love the design of this show truly but
this department with
all sorts of time tech is using a clunky
industrial age robot for intake
my cognitive dissonance is rising and
you know how much i hate my own
cognitive dissonance
absolutely not this is fine as guardian
leather
a robot that may or may not be sentient
attempts to use the creepy pinchers
before using the much faster
and more efficient disintegration ray
this particular robot arm
please sign to verify this is everything
you've ever said this sets up a clever
joke but
what's the point of it first even if
they tried to read it all there's no way
anyone could verify what they've said
in second why would it matter to the tva
to have your acknowledgment anyway
hiddleston clearly only signs the final
sheet here even though he was asked to
sign all three
make him sign all three like you said is
this a scathing satire of bureaucracy or
not
take a ticket what is this a deli
no kids welcome to the time variants
authority
exposition via queue line video
featuring a cute animated mascot
otherwise known as jurassic park's
position except there it made more sense
since it was at an actual amusement park
the tva
has stepped in to fix your mistake and
set time back on its predetermined path
i'm gonna have to remove a sin for
cleverly introducing us to the very
morally questionable act of erasing
timelines
is there even a word for what tva is
doing chronoside
murderverse whatever it is megaman a
plus for introducing this incredibly
devious premise with this cheeky cartoon
created a nexus event which left
unchecked
could branch off into madness you mean
like the nexus mentioned in one division
could lead to the multiverse of
madness marvel you've done it again and
by
it i mean throw so many easter eggs at
me that i'm now numb to what reality
even is anymore
owen wilson speaking french sir there's
something you'll want to see
the worst kinds of you better take a
look at this cliches are the ones that
are self-evident
you traveled through time to bring him
this file you're handing it to him i
think he's well aware that you might
consider it something he'd want to see
varian l-1130 aka loki
laufen is charged with sequence
violation 720-89
how do you plead no explanation of the
charges against loki is given at this
trial i vehemently disagree with the
lack of transparency in the judicial
processes employed by the tva
good thing this is only fiction huh as
zoan wilson arrives late to this trial i
just have to ask
if this place exists outside of time how
does it operate within its own time
like why would owen never be late to
anything could he just come back from
ancient france at a time that would get
him to the trial in a more punctual
manner how are people who travel through
time on a daily basis ever late for
anything
we're not here to talk about the
avengers marvel pleading with audiences
to love anything after
the infinity saga somehow makes it into
the episode i thought there was no magic
here
there isn't most of what we see looks a
lot like a massive space station
considering all the fantastical stuff
we've seen so far in the mcu
are we supposed to be awed by this why a
scene
the idea that your little club decides
the fate of trillions of people across
all of existence at the behest of three
space lizards yes it's funny it's absurd
loki would be glorious at tv sins for
the record this really does feel like a
killing me kind of a room
does it i mean it does kind of have a
brutalist vibe that i'm not a fan of
however it's balanced out by warm tones
and some interesting mid-century modern
accent pieces not to mention the
baseboard lighting
if i were murdered in this room it would
be completely my fault for misreading
the situation
can we get some rules on this reset
collar thing does it send the person
back a certain number of seconds
to a predetermined geolocation because
over the course of the show it will
somehow do both
the timekeepers have built quite the
circus
and i see the clowns are playing their
parts to perfection
big metaphor guy i love it wilson and
hiddleston are so good in this scene and
show that i have to take a sin off but
mobius's responses to loki are never
ending loop of being excellent at tv
sins so i'm kind of stuck in a catch-22
here which of course is our way of
saying that the show's gonna catch 22
cents here for making me question my
ability to do my job
sorry them's the rules what is this it's
a fancy reverse expositional device
we call it the previously on the mcu
machine and for the next 30 minutes it's
going to do all the plots heavy lifting
in increasingly more and more convenient
ways
did the avengers come together to
literally avenge him by defeating you
little solace to a dead man sure but
actually fury cre-corpsed him back to
life with project tahiti
sorry tay hit i so that he could keep
working are you going to mention that
oh great timekeeper we won't stand for
agents of
hell to erasure around these parts do
you enjoy hurting people
making them feel small youtube commenter
recruitment ads
yes this is mischievous but if loki and
thor were gonna go through the trouble
of putting together this whole scheme
just for the thrill of it i feel like
loki especially would have requested
something more interesting than paper
currency
i'm not sure what we have here that
would appeal to an asgardian but two
hundred thousand dollars seems like it
wouldn't be worth their time
this tva logo is actually kind of badass
with its old school feel and the hidden
hourglass between the v
and the a am i about to take a sin off
for excellent graphic design
the sacred syn line deems it so
apparently but also when i said hidden
between the v
and the a i immediately thought of
taints so the sacred sin line gives and
the sacred sin line takes away i guess
the times position device is apparently
using the same camera movement from the
movie
why is sheamus mcgarvey the dp of the
sacred timeline as well
what are you doing my job is it your
standard
yes
right not only is he a great pickpocket
but he quickly figured out how to use
the time device that for some reason was
built without any safety or security
features how do you not know what a fish
is
i live my entire life behind it does
this is not an acceptable answer you can
be taught about things that you will
never experience
it's basically the whole reason the kama
sutra even exists
also casey is a liar are you behind your
desk right now
casey are you case closed infinity stars
oh come on sure it's a funny joke that
they're worthless here and have many
versions discarded through time but just
because they hold no power here doesn't
mean they wouldn't be protected from
someone getting a hold of them and using
them back in the sacred
timeline for beings charged with
protecting time their evidence
processing system is less organized than
my desk drawer in elementary school
no one in this scene is concerned about
the obvious variant standing
unaccompanied by any sort of security
force in the middle of this office
this leads me to believe that either
this sequence of events is expected or
that every one of these workers is burnt
out and no longer gives two facts about
the sacred timeline
hunter b-15 is a dick to office supplies
and has absolutely zero concern in
regard to possibly killing her co-worker
the company culture here is atrocious
this episode is all about this version
of loki reckoning with the misdeeds of
his past and the loss of a life that he
will no longer be able to live
sure it's well written and performed
beautifully but i can't help but feel
like the overall goal here is to reshape
this loki into the one that died in
infinity war
this loki has to experience a quickie
evolution as if it's his character arc
that is somehow sacred convenient fast
forward to this exact moment is
convenient
you know this would be pretty cool if we
understood how any of this actually
worked but
you just keep rocking that pointless
remix depokey the variant we're hunting
is
you
[Music]
oklahoma doesn't exist no seriously in
1858 the state of oklahoma didn't
officially exist
didn't become a state until 1907. thanks
for visiting the tva
don't hesitate to let us know how we're
doing you made me sit through six
minutes of credits to hear this one
lousy question is how i'm doing you time
juggling chrono bastards
you've just been erased this is fine
and guardian leather leather of course
why not the best
a hundred million years ago there were
mosquitoes
just like today and just like today
they fit on the blood of animals
[Music]
welcome to alpha the city of a thousand
planets
why does someone with so much range
just want to rule it's really not that
complicated
i got read in my ledger i'd like to wipe
it out
what exactly is it that you want i'll
tell you one thing that really
drives me nuts is people that think that
jethro tall is just a person in the band
give me the tesseract or i'll gut you
like a fish casey what's a
you fish and get you like a fish